lucky I think that he was supposed to
send a helmet to the Hall of Fame and
didn't send the game used helmet to the
Hall of Fame yes who there's this one
piece I'm reading an article about it
exhibit 18 I know it well doesn't sound
very good for him because it's an email
in which someone says hey Joe my buddy
was offered in Eli game-used helmet and
jersey are those the BS one Eli asked
you to make up because he didn't want to
give up the real stuff and the reply to
the email is BS ones you are correct
that almost sounds like they were under
investigation already like it was
evidence they were set up and like you
have to get them on wiretap admitting
everything exactly to the murder in the
car with the weapon at the time all of
that I mean a clue yeah at least the BS
one eli has to there's no BS with this
guy he said frank isola with the new
york daily news Frank is just a big deal
should this be a bigger deal with Eli
Manning i was going to say i bought a
dan patrick game warning sunday night
football sports coat and now you're
trying to tell me it could be fake ya
know it is fake you just make you dirty
rat yes just like my hair it's fake
Frank I'm the same way by the way here's
my thing about Eli Manning person I
heard you guys talking about it he's got
so much money already why like why do
you want to go down this road with this
nonsense I knew I do think it's a big
deal i think when you get into this
whole world of merchandise and
memorabilia you know or guys paying
taxes for stuff like there's no the
whole thing to be a seems to be little
shady that's for sure but does the NFL
get involved in this at some point well
i'll bet you a team like New England we
hope that the NFL would get involved cuz
they certainly got involved with Tom
Brady you're going to tell me that's an
on the field thing absolutely but this
this does deal with off the field and
they do get involved in issues like that
I'm just surprised because you know Eli
Manning has a squeaky-clean image and as
you guys know the giants their go kind
of the one team in New York that's kind
of seen as you know more than the other
is the class organization but the Giants
are also good at spinning stuff so
though they'll make it out to be that it
was a charitable thing that the Eli
Manning did somehow they were they're
able to spin it the great Pat Hanlon
could spin it some way how is this PR
guy by the way how surprised were you
that
Christy called out a lineman calling a
liar how incredible is that when some a
some of the things he's been involved in
and we know that he loves to hug Jerry
Jones when the Cowboys score a touchdown
in the playoffs which doesn't happen
often so like but you know what we also
know what this is dan chris christie is
looking to compete against you because
he wants to become a radio sports talk
show host so I think that's I think
that's part of it to be somewhat
controversial get his name out there
because I think that's because that
could be where he's headed well that's
the normal progression is that you go
from governor to the sports talk show so
I understand that I don't know where I
go after this but I know it's run for
president he ran for president I thing
you don't have I prank give me the last
week summarized the last week for the
New York Knicks ah probably much like
most of the past 17 years a lot of chaos
a lot of dysfunction and I think you
know on Friday when Phil Jackson came
out and you know really but you know
trying to paint the picture that
everything will be fine once Carmelo
Anthony leaves and I think there's a lot
of people how to convince you know what
he's probably right about that and then
the situation with Christopher zynga's
or have a young player who's 21 years
old you know saying enough with this
nonsense and doesn't show up for his
exit meeting and I'm not condoning that
your boss tells you to show up and first
of all you you are as a 21 year old kid
and that's you know Phil Jackson Steve
Mills those you know that and and the
head coach is gonna be there and you
blow them off that's not a good look and
you know if LeBron had done that if
Carmelo had done that Kobe Bryant can
you imagine the reaction that you would
get so he doesn't he shouldn't be a
working class hero for doing that but I
do think it speaks to a larger issue
that you know it is there's a lot of
nonsense that goes on the organization a
kid like pros ingress is only 21 he's
been a professional player since he was
about 15 16 in Spain so he kind of knows
how the game works and I don't think he
likes the way the Nick organization is
headed and for that I do give him credit
to be kind of that smart and you know
kind of willing to put himself out there
and skip that meeting but what about the
Carmelo situation of he knows he's not
one good he stills going to get paid is
there a chance that he just makes it so
they have to cut
him and also his personal life now it's
reported and you had it today in the
daily news of he separated from his wife
may be headed for divorce and as he
headed for two divorces here ya know
that that's a good point and you know
obviously it adds a wrinkle to what
could happen here the sun with caramel
you know the one thing to remember about
Carmela besides the fact that he was
smart enough to get in on trade clause
in his contract that same contract
includes a trade kicker so he would make
a lot of heat make actually more money
if he does get rated but you know i do
think that carmelo and is agent Lee on
Rose if they decide you know what
Carmela likes it here we're going to
force the Knicks hand and make the
Knicks cuts now the Knicks could say all
right you know what you stay here we're
going to make you the six-man little
Carmelo wouldn't be thrilled with doing
but by becoming a free agent obviously
he would then be able to you know pick
and choose where he wants to go and he
has said you know he was probably
dropping hints over the past year
because he kept talking about waiving
his trade no trade clause and he kept
talking about how much his family enjoys
it here and his son is in an a you know
a popular AAU program in New York son
likes going to school here that doesn't
mean there are other places in the
country where the kid can't go to school
and play for an AAU team but i think the
Carmelo i think the fact that his son is
comfortable and the Carmelo is on the
road you know 441 road games a year i
think i think he likes the fact that he
has a foundation here so i think all
things being equal carmella doesn't want
to leave but let's also remember we have
a lot of time between now and the start
of the regular season what is this
tenure done to Phil Jackson's legacy III
think when you look at Michael Jordan
you know people still look at Michael
Jordan as a great player that's not to
say that Michael Jordan hasn't had a
couple of good years here with chart so
I think with Phil I think it hurts his
legacy from the standpoint that it
wasn't just him in these you know these
great teams in Chicago in LA and I think
he probably has a lot more respect now
for Jerry Krause and for Jerry West how
difficult it is sometimes to put this
whole thing together so I think he's
always going to be remembered as a great
coach but you know it's hard to say no
that he that he has the chops to be a
great executive it's a hundred sixty six
losses after three seasons and
after he went for it last summer inside
Noah traded for Derrick Rose sign
Jennings and sign Courtney Lee the next
still ended up with more losses this
year than they did last year so he still
has a hundred sixty six losses and after
three years he's not telling me he wants
to rebuild can you they build though
with the Knicks and you know it's like
the Lakers that there's a certain
standard that's their granted it's a
lower standard with the Knicks but can
you just say hey we're going to get
worse before we get better a hundred
percent and I think that's always the
mistake of everyone that takes over the
team that should be there the first
thing they say because the fans are
definitely willing to be patient with
something like that and the Knicks are
still selling out every game so I say I
don't think that's ever going to be a
problem I actually think it's easier in
a market like New York and I think a lot
of fans now they like the great unknown
and that's why everyone's so focused on
the NFL Draft and the NBA Draft because
they think that every player in the
draft is going to be the guy that's
going to change their franchise so I
definitely think you can do it in New
Yorkers here's the thing they've been
rebuilding in New York they just haven't
admitted it now Phil Jackson is
admitting it now that he wants to
rebuild and that's only because he's
trying to buy himself more time after
three failed seasons but I think the
fans aren't as demanding as people think
that they are I think they're a lot of
people like going to the games to see
who the celebrities are to see you know
what stars are on another team I do
think there are hardcore fans are upset
with it but I think for the most part in
New York you can rebuild here's looking
good on pardon the interruption there
Frank thanks dad from you I definitely
take that as a cop I'd appreciate and
you should thank you that's Frank I so
look the knicks NBA beat writer New York
Daily News also occasional around the
horn and gets an upgrade their to pardon
the interruption co-host as well the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience